Humans and animals
are hardwired to endure
and that includes our
"Hostile Planet" crew
who had to go through
so much to bring
you this incredible footage.
RENEE GODFREY: We were filming
the bat sequence in New Mexico
in the middle of the
baking hot desert
to capture this amazing
emergence of thousands
of bats in the evening light.
MARK MACEWAN: They snake
out of these huge caves.
But-- well, that's
great and they look
great when they're doing that.
But you don't want
to be in the cave
when they're doing that
because in the cave is hideous.
You're in there.
And you are just being
rained on with bat feces
and urine all over the place.
When that's not
happening, there are
flesh-eating beetles falling off
the ceiling trying to bite you.
You look at the floor
and it's crawling
with maggots and beetle larvae.
It's like Mordor.
And the ammonia is
ridiculously strong.
If we wander in there, I will
die within minutes if I'm not
wearing a full
respirator kit, which
in the middle of the
desert in 100% humidity
is the last thing
you really want.
The visor is filling with sweat.
It's like in a
leaky diving mask.
OK.
Now, for the surgical gloves.
There's a massive
amount of preparation
before going into the bat cave.
It's to protect ourselves.
But it's also to stop
us taking anything
in that could impact
or contaminate
the bats' environment.
It's just this crazy
ritual every day
that we had to do if we
wanted to go into the cave.
The snake test.
MARK MACEWAN: The cave
that these bats live in is
in a very steep-sided gorge.
And climbing down there
is sort of snake alley.
We'd have to throw
stones everywhere
to try and give it a warning
that we're coming down.
You crawl down into these
huge, steep cave systems
in these suits
that you can't tear
or have any imperfections in.
And suddenly, you realized
you were going somewhere that
wasn't really meant for you.
RENEE GODFREY: It's
like walking on snow.
You're walking in on
big piles of guano.
You can see why you need
to wear the respirators
because with each
footstep, a cloud of dust
comes up from the dry powder.
MARK MACEWAN: So
we'd have this moment
where we've set all the cameras
and we'd sit and we'd wait.
If we got lucky, they'd
come out, but only
for probably 10 minutes.
The whole event is
over in 10 minutes.
RENEE GODFREY: It
is extraordinary
as they shoot out past you.
You just get this rush of air
and this flap of their wings,
which I know we captured
with the Phantom
at 1,000 frames a
second beautifully.
MARK MACEWAN: What
we were after was
bats being predated by hawks.
And these hawks come
flying in from nowhere
and are just picking
bats out of the sky.
And what we were kind of
really interested in in sort
of the movement into
shots and trying
to use high-speed
technology to really capture
the moment of the capture.
[music playing]
RENEE GODFREY: The bat
cave in New Mexico,
it's not the most glamorous
of environments to work in,
that's for sure.
But then the bats start to swirl
out as the evening light begins
and suddenly you see
this amazing spectacle
happening before your eyes.
And it makes it worth it.
[music playing]